Speaker 1: OK.
Let's hear from a few more people via Discord
David Pakman dot com slash discord if you'd
like to chat with me.
Let's go next to let's go to Bob from Colorado,
Bob from Colorado.
You're on.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave, how are you doing?
I'm doing well.
Yes, so I got a question, I've been seeing
news reports recently that.
You see a lot of the MAGA people basically
accidentally supporting liberal policies like
I saw recently that exactly what it was, but
there were attempts to break up tech monopolies
like Facebook and Twitter.
And it had bipartisan support in both the
left and a lot of the MAGA people.
Yeah.
Do you think?
We might end up seeing a lot of accidental
liberal policies kind of from.
Speaker 3: I don't want to say out of ignorance,
but kind of out of ignorance.
Speaker 1: Yes, I mean, what's going on is
a lot of these MAGA people are going against
their stated principles just because they
want to own the libs or companies they perceive
to be on the left.
So for example, like all these MAGA people
are like regulations bad.
Let's not regulate companies.
But then, like Facebook, bans their favorite
conservative anti-vaxxer and all of a sudden
they go, Oh, we got to regulate that.
We've got to regulate.
We've got to regulate Facebook.
All of a sudden.
So I think that at the end of the day, they
don't really have an interest in regulating
companies.
They don't really have an interest in enforcing
antitrust.
They've not expressed any interest in that.
And I think what's going to stop a lot of
this stuff from becoming legislation is if
they get close to saying we're going to pass
a more robust antitrust infrastructure to
break up some of these tech companies, their
big funders in the corporate world will say,
Hey, if you do that, it will also affect us
and then they'll back off of it.
That's my prediction.
Speaker 3: So you don't think we're going
to see any big changes?
Speaker 1: I really don't know.
Not if it depends on the MAGA people.
Like if politics get realigned, then yes.
But not not thanks to the MAGA people.
Speaker 2: OK, and one more question.
How do you feel about the right to repair?
I guess move men are bills that are passed
that are going on right now and do you think
we're going to see anything
Speaker 3: positive come out of that?
I am
Speaker 1: hopeful.
I generally favor right to repair, which relates
to a lot of different issues, including intellectual
property and some other things.
Generally speaking, I favor right to repair,
but on any particular bill, you know, I have
to look at the bill to say for sure.
Speaker 2: There definitely seems to be bipartisan
support for that as well, because I know a
lot of
Speaker 3: rural farmers in the like are supporting
that.
To be able to fix equipment and all that.
Speaker 1: Yes, absolutely.
Yep, no, I think it's a it's a worthwhile
movement.
Speaker 3: OK, thank you.
Dave, you answered all my questions today.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you very much.
There's there's Bob.
Great to hear from Bob.
Let's go next to is it?
Said Joe from Spain.
Sado from Spain.
Speaker 2: Oh, yes, hello.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hi, nice to meet you.
Yeah, it's so believe it or not, I think it's
better.
You will, Mindy.
And yeah, I wanted to ask a question, but
I'd like to give a little bit of context before
so you guys can see where I'm coming from.
Because seeing the lobby, I might be the only
one not from the US right now.
Speaker 1: That's fine.
We just want a direct path to your question.
You know, we try to avoid monologues.
There's too extensive.
Speaker 2: Yeah, basically, I just wanted
to say that in Spain, I don't know how many
of you would be familiar with the political
context here that I intend to tell my American
friends a lot that the right wing extremists
in Spain would be considered communists in
the US, basically because of their propaganda
turns around the conservation of the of the
social governments, right?
And it appeals, you know, to all the folks
and stuff like that.
And all in Europe, you see many perspectives
that really aren't at all what you see in
the political context in the US.
And I could give more context if you want
in several different issues, but I basically
wanted to ask you, right?
Are you aware, maybe you as what you Americans
call liberal or Americans in general, are
you aware of how crazy and toxic your politics
are perceived or perceived overseas?
Speaker 1: I am very aware of it.
I mean, listen, I have family in a lot of
different countries, and so I am regularly
getting the feedback that American politics
are toxic and insane.
We also have viewers, you know, 20 percent
of our viewers are not in the United States.
And so I get emails all the time from people
in Denmark or Spain or anywhere saying it's
insane what's going on in the United States.
So yes, I am very much aware that this is
not normal here.
Speaker 2: But I know you are.
Because as you say, you used people, but a
lot of people on, you know, many international
people I know.
But do you think there is, so to speak, a
consensus within the country?
No, I think a lot
Speaker 1: of people have no idea.
Certainly, there's a lot of people that have
no idea and that I can't answer for them,
but there's many people that don't know what's
going on in other countries.
Speaker 2: Yeah, fair enough.
So I would say it's a bit interesting if I'm
from the European perspective.
I think we see the United States as being
overly focused within itself.
Whilst the rest of the world can know a lot
about the US, every single country that has
its sights on the US will probably be a complete
mystery for Americans.
Speaker 1: Many Americans are completely self-centered
in their news consumption, for sure.
OK, single from Spain.
Thank you so much for the call.
I'm going to leave you to the crinkly paper.
Whatever you've got going on there, very,
very much.
Appreciate it.
Let's go next.
Where do we go next?
Because there's just it's it's it's crazy
what's happening on the phones right now.
If you if you saw what was happening on the
phones, you would be you would be shocked.